I just want to eat some ass is that too
much - no no Inder is the epitome of
everything that's terrible about society
today you're using your thumb to decide
whether you would basically sleep with
that person or not based on looks what
are you doing on to intercept oh my god
ha ha uh it's fun to do with friends and
just look at this stupid idiot oh I do
not trust myself I need to discuss it
with somebody and really go over it and
then when you when you get a match it's
that much more fun because you can
celebrate the match with your friend hey
I got a girl he likes we're gonna get
married
ha ha ha now he's gonna message me and I
don't want him to yes or no no thank you
no no no no no no no no no oh my god yes
yes yes yes yes yes swipe right men are
disgusting change up your bio change up
your style your life looks boring I'm
not interested maybe try to grow your
hair out or work out a little bit yeah
selfie selfie selfie selfie gym gym
selfie no fee selfie selfie ok do you
think that this was a self-timer pic
kind of yeah like press the photo booth
run right back I like there's a Warren
in this picture she's a friend Tommy
with a girl is that your ex or something
it's his sister or they're trying to
share us someone's honking mark his mom
his mother his mom
are these Jefferies co-workers sisters
and friends they're swingers okay this
guy completely crapped out his
ex-girlfriend dropped his ex-girlfriend
out dropping X out he's about to make
out with another girl in the picture if
you have a picture with a girl you just
don't know how to use tinder and not you
don't know how to use life chuckle he's
ripped hot hot hot hot he's cute cute
cute cute cute he is handsome he's a
handsome guy Oh naked naked naked naked
oh no well he's on
just topless this is disgusting yeah
real naked selfie is a double negative
lumpy odd muscles like lumpy he looks at
a South American Ken doll five loaves of
bread he actually has breasts showing
off their bodies good just looking good
is good I like smiling that's creepy
this is creepy kind of creepy creepy
weirdo creepy creeper creepy hmm
you're scary-looking i Adam so nervous I
can't believe we haven't seen any dog
photos yet we haven't weird cat a dog
cat dog dog
yeah that dog this guy's a monkey on his
shoulder he's weak he can't even hold
the dog he has a dog now there's a
picture with a panda is it dog gonna
join in
puppies are always good oh [ __ ] a
picture with a whale it's like I can't
do all that for dick Jared with the
child and a camel swiping left
this is hate when people put me on
canine later no kid pictures we don't
want any baggage Oh baby can't child
children little dudes not mine here he
is with a kid that's not his don't put a
photo with the child on tinder it's
about sex it's so weird
Ian who are you out of three don't know
which one he is because there are two
people no it was unclear which guy he
actually was if there's two people in
the picture I don't time for the [ __ ]
Rhett that's a good group photo because
they already know who he is it's been
established don't you have friends it
means you have fun hat hot tubs hat I
just don't trust hats
The Paperboy hat is like an automatic no
bandana always kind of said screams no
his suit doesn't match the suit
don't shoot with money in his mouth ooh
I like his suit I like a suit like a
shoes dress choose from 2002 a suit
picture will always get you a swipe
right as long as you're also hot it is a
lot of accessories that is a lot of
accessories shorts oh he doesn't have
pants on pink shirt floral shirt yellow
shirts not not cutting it for me no
suspenders scarf scarf cigar purple tie
know what goes well with a vest
virginity the very first photo should be
very clear of you
probably alone none of this [ __ ]
with other people in the photo it's
weird
no duckface no drunk no taking shots out
of someone's cleavage no shots out of
bellybuttons no pictures with kids I'm
never more shallow than I am on tinder